if we Republicans choose Donald Trump as
our nominee the prospect for a safe and
prosperous future are greatly diminished
let me explain why I say that first on
the economy
if Donald Trump's plans were ever
implemented the country would sink into
prolonged recession a few examples his
proposed 35% tariff like penalties would
instigate a trade war and that would
raise prices for consumers kill our
export jobs and lead entrepreneurs and
businesses of all stripes to flee
America this tax plan in combination
with his refusal to reform entitlements
and to honestly address spending would
balloon the deficit and the national
debt so even though Donald Trump has
offered very few specific economic plans
what little he has said is enough to
know that he would be very bad for
American workers and for American
families but you say wait wait wait is
it he a huge business success doesn't he
know what he's talking about no he isn't
and no he doesn't
look his his bankruptcies have crushed
small businesses and the men and women
who work for them he inherited his
business he didn't create it and
whatever happened to trump Airlines how
about Trump University
and then there's Trump magazine and
Trump vodka and Trump steaks and Trump
mortgage a business genius he is not now
not every policy that Donald Trump is
floated as bad of course he wants to
repeal and replace Obamacare he wants to
bring jobs home from China and Japan but
his prescriptions to do those things are
flimsy at best at the last debate all
they could remember about his health
care plan was to remove insurance
boundaries between states successfully
bringing jobs home requires serious
policy and reforms that make America the
place businesses want to come want to
plant and want to grow you can't punish
business into doing what you want
frankly the only serious policy
proposals that deal with a broad range
of national challenges we confront today
come from Ted Cruz Marco Rubio and John
Kasich one of these men should be our
nominee